hot breath with such a unique style do
you ever find yourself still having
similar jokes with any other comics the
whole
parallel thinking thing yeah of course
yeah yeah not all the time but sometimes
i was in montreal having a good time
doing some jokes about
koalas and koalas having chlamydia that
i found that out when i went to
australia
and then i went to go see um dulce sloan
afterwards and she was pretty much doing
the same exact
and it was really fun i talked to her
afterwards and i was just like hey like
i just want to let you know
i'm doing a koala bit about going to
australia
you're doing in chlamydia like they were
different different
like arcs on it but for the most part
it's just like
koalas chlamydia and so i was like i
don't plan to
stop i don't think i'm going to put it
in anything but i it's funny and fun
so i'm going to keep working on it you
keep working on yours
i just want to let you know i'm doing it
and then most of all i just love
that two young black comedians both went
to australia
oh yeah so you just keep writing about
it you're like even though someone else
is doing it i'm still going to do my
version of it
yeah i mean you know there's a
difference of like street jokes and like
one to one just copies but if you're
talking
your life you're talking relationships
you're talking things you're
there's nothing new under the sun you
know so you're gonna run into the same
topics i think a lot of comedians do
themselves a disservice
by like not wanting to talk about the
mundane not talk
wanting to talk about subjects that have
been done before
but it's like your view if it's truthful
and if it's your reality then i want to
hear that too i want to hear that like
i i love that especially as i get older
and like
i'm like oh like there's these 20 year
old comics talking about drugs i've
never heard
before and sexual positions i've never
done before
and so i should probably just talk about
being a homeowner and
the things i'm doing yeah yeah
to them yeah we had alonzo bowden on
here
who is known to be great at topical
humor and his his whole thing was to
make it uniquely you
is to put it through your point of view
that's basically how you make any
general topic unique to you and your
voice
yeah just talk about what you know about
you know that's
the thing i hate the most is when you
see comedians and they like oh this is a
topic everybody's talking about so i
need to talk about it and a lot of times
like
nothing worse to me than like seeing
someone do a story
like some male comic doing jokes about
abortion
that never experienced that never
took someone to go get one never went
through that thing like
to me though like the exact opposite is
like
i don't know if you've heard it i assume
anthony jessel makes abortion joke about
taking a lady to the abortion clinic
like
it's a sweet joke it's a hilarious joke
it's a
mean joke just like he'd likes to do but
it's truthful and it's
honest and that's what i love about it
instead of someone just doing an
abortion joke because they think
it's a taboo subject to talk about